la mère fois que je vous ai présenté le
problème des deux enveloppes vous avez
deux enveloppes devant vous l'une
d'elles contient le double du montant de
l'autre vous choisissez l'une des
enveloppes au hasard vous l'ouvrez et
vous voyez qu'elle contient 2 euros mais
maintenant je vous offre la possibilité
d'échanger et enveloppes
que faites vous vous pouvez aussi poser
cette question sur twitter il 62%
d'entre vous décidez de changer d'
enveloppe un peu surpris que vous soyez
autant vous êtes 17% sur twitter a gardé
les deux euros et 20 % à dire que ça ne
changera rien j'ai refait le même
sondage mais avec cette fois 20 euros à
la place des deux euros et là ça passe à
50,29 et 21 et pour une découverte de 10
euros sachant que l'autre enveloppe
contient dix fois plus ou dix fois moins
non mais à 78 10 et 11
ce problème a surtout conduit à de longs
échanges aussi bien dans les
commentaires youtube que dans les
discussions sur twitter et je trouve ça
vraiment super chouette de voir que des
milliers de personnes parmi vous
réfléchissent à ce délicieux problème
d'autant que ce qui rend ce problème
particulièrement délicieux c'est que un
peu comme le paradoxe des deux enfants
il s'agit un peu d'une montagne russe de
downing kruger dans le sens où il ya
plusieurs fois dans ce paradoxe on peut
se dire ça y est j'ai compris avant de
se rendre compte plus tard que en fait
non c'est encore un peu plus compliqué
que ce que je croyais et personnellement
j'adore les problèmes qui conduisent à
ce genre de phénomène qu'on peut
retrouver d'ailleurs dans d'autres
thèmes que j'ai déjà abordé comme la
gravité les sommes infini où les
fondations mathématiques
sauf que contrairement à ses autres
problèmes là on a un cas extrêmement
simple sachant que j'ai tiré une
enveloppe avec 2 euros et que l'autre
enveloppe contient le double ou la
moitié de mes 2 euros doivent garder mes
2 euros ou est-ce qu'il vaudrait mieux
que je change d'angle up ou encore est
ce que changer ou nombre d' enveloppe ne
change finalement rien si vous n'y avez
pas encore réfléchi je vous invite
vivement à mettre pause et à réfléchir
maintenant
alors bien sûr il ya beaucoup de
facteurs qui interviennent dans la
réponse qu'on pourra donner en pratique
notamment à quel point on a besoin de 2
euros et quel point on a tendance à
aimer les paris que résister qu'on peut
avoir pour le contenu de l'autre
enveloppe et d'autres facteurs
psychologiques encore mais les matheux
parmi vous ou disons les aspirants
baliser un parmi vous ont sans doute
envie de plutôt déterminer une solution
qui consisterait à maximiser quelque
chose comme l'espérance de gain combien
d'argent en espérance gagnerait ton
alors à changer d' enveloppe
sachant que l'on à deux euros et que
notre enveloppe contient la moitié ou le
double l'autre enveloppe contient
forcément un euro ou 4 euros
ok mais alors l'espérance de gain en
moyenne ça semble être un + 4 / 2 ce qui
fait deux euros et 50 centimes mais
alors gagneraient en moyenne 50 centimes
en plus en changeant enveloppe le calcul
par espérance de gain conclurait alors
que nice gagne à changer d' enveloppe
sauf que sauf que ce raisonnement en
fait assez étrange si on y réfléchit
bien en particulier ne semble pas
dépendre de la somme de 2 euros qu'on a
trouvé dans notre enveloppe
si on avait tiré 20 euros le même
raisonnement nous aurait conduit à
conclure qu'on y gagne en espérance 10
puces 40 / dose qui fait 25 euros soit 5
euros de plus à changer
en fait selon ce raisonnement il
faudrait toujours changer et ça ça peut
pas assez absurde
pourquoi l'enveloppent qu'on n'a pas
choisi initialement contiendrait
systématiquement en espérance plus
d'argent pour prendre conscience de
l'absurdité de cette conclusion
imaginons qu'on ne découvre pas le
contenu de notre enveloppe pour une taxe
de 1% sur le mouton finale on aurait
alors intérêt à changer d' enveloppe
mais alors si vous nous redonne l'option
d'échangé à nouveau dans l'op
après le premier échanges avec une taxe
de 1 % par le même raisonnement ou
serait encore tentaient d'échanger d'env
loeb
sauf que si on échange deuxième fois
dans glop où se retrouvent avec l'
enveloppe initiale mais avec une taxe de
1 % + 1 % x 86 9%
pire ce processus des changes pour être
reconduit à l'infini et après 500
échanges seraient taxés à plus de 99%
bref cette absurdité c'est le signe que
l'épistémologie qu'ont utilisé pour
conclure qu'il faut changer d' enveloppe
est très satisfaisante
est ce que vous voyez où est l'erreur
dans notre raisonnement je vous invite à
vraiment un métro pause pour réfléchir
alors petite parenthèse avant de crier
leur raisonnement qu'on vient de voir
certaines épistémologique qui se
prétendent parfois être la méthode
scientifique encourage à s'abstenir dans
l'ignorance imagine que dans ce cas ce
rapport à une nuance reviendrait du coup
à ne pas décider
et ça ça paraît en fait tout aussi
insatisfaisant est-ce qu'il faudra en
particulier renoncé ou 2 euros
est-ce qu'il faudra systématiquement ne
pas prendre des décisions dans
l'ignorance comme c'était le cas au
hasard au début du comité 19
probablement pas il semble qu'une bonne
épistémologique doit nous aiguiller dans
la prise de décision fin de la plante
est ok revenons-en un autre raisonnement
allez vous trouver sa faiblesse bien
l'erreur dans notre raisonnement c'est
ce qu'on pourrait appeler le sophisme du
50 50
ce qu'on sait effectivement c'est que
l'autre enveloppe contient la moitié ou
le double et on n'a par ailleurs pas
assez de données pour déterminer si
elles contenaient la moitié ou le double
dans l'ignorance ou s'est précipité pour
conclure que les deux cas étaient est
plus probable visiblement c'est là que
le bât blesse
cette description de l'ignorance par une
loi à 50 50
et en fait problématique puisqu'elle
nous a conduits vers un échange infinie
durant lequel notre gain fondait comme
neige au soleil
et malheureusement beaucoup de gens très
brillants font une confusion
systématique entre l'absence de
connaissance on appelle aussi je ne sais
pas et la description de cette ignorance
par un 50 50
pire encore ce principe visiblement
fallacieux et souvent formalisé par des
pseudos bayésiens qu'il appelle le
principe d'entropie maximale et qui le
présente parfois comme la bonne façon de
définir un préjugé raisonnable en cas de
connaissance imparfaite et ça en fait
en général ce n'est vraiment pas
parisien j'y reviendrai
avant cela je vais analyser une autre
réponse récurrente dans les commentaires
à savoir l'idée selon laquelle le fait
de changer d' enveloppe ou non ne change
rien typiquement on peut avoir le
raisonnement suivant les deux enveloppes
contiennent forcément x et 2x weeks et
du coup le plus faible contenu parmi les
deux enveloppes en espérance
l'enveloppent choisi initialement
contient x + 2 x divisée par deux ce qui
fait 3 x divisé par deux mais l'autre
enveloppe contient le même montant donc
changer ou non ne change rien car dans
les deux cas l'espérance de gain est
égal à 3 x / de hockey mais comme vous
l'aurez deviné ce raisonnement n'est pas
la solution by viennent du problème tout
cas celle que je propose est ce que vous
voyez pourquoi est ce que vous voyez ce
qui cloche dans ce raisonnement est bien
le problème c'est que ce raisonnement
ignore une donnée du problème
en fait il s'agit d'un raisonnement tout
à fait juste si on suppose qu'on ne
découvre pas le contenu de l'enveloppé
initialement choisie mais le
raisonnement attire raison d'ignorer
cette donnée imaginez que vous avez
promis de reverser 5 % de vos gains à
votre ami et que celui-ci vous dise
discrètement à l'oreille qui connaît
très bien les organisateurs de
l'expérience et qu'il pense très
fortement que cet organisateur a mis des
montants égaux à 2 euros et 4 euros
est ce que vous auriez alors raison
d'ignorer cette données fournies par
votre ami plus généralement ignoré une
donnée du problème sous la demande de
justification
surtout dans un cadre bayésiens des
données qui peuvent paraître
anecdotiques peuvent souvent en fait
indirectement nous informer sur des
choses a priori très peu relier je vous
renvoie vers le paradoxe des deux
enfants pour bien vous en rendre compte
en fait il ya même tout un champ de
recherche en informatique appelé la
théorie de la confidentialité
différentiel defence of privacy en
anglais qui cherche justement à garantir
l'absence de fuite d'informations
personnelles indirects et spoiler à
l'heure il faut des algorithmes
adéquatement conçu et parfois très
sophistiqués pour y parvenir en
particulier dans notre cas il semble que
l'information sur le contenu de
l'envelope on a choisi n'est pas si
anecdotique ou du moins il faudra
justifier la raison pour laquelle cette
donnée devrait changer ou non notre
calcul de l'espérance de gain en
changeant développe en fait de façon
générale il existe un théorème bayésiens
qui affirme que en espérance on y gagne
nécessairement à acquérir et inclure
plus de données pour prendre de
meilleures décisions
bon il ya quelques technicalité qu'il
faut préciser pour éviter les contresens
et que je mets ici en petits caractères
mais si on attribue bien une
interprétation bayésienne aux
probabilités et en particulier aux
espérances ce théorème nous invite
constamment à acquérir davantage
d'informations pour améliorer nos
calculs contractuels
ok ça y est on y vient voici la solution
by viennent du problème si vous avez
bien suivi cette série j'espère qu'elle
vous est venue en tête pour être au
brésil
il faut commencer par déterminer notre
préjugés a priori à quelle somme
d'argent
faut-il s'attendre quelles sont les
sommes probable que contiennent les deux
enveloppes clairement les réponses à
fournir à ces questions sont extrêmement
contextuel si c'est moi qui vous pose
concrètement ce problème avec une vraie
promesse de don ce sera très différent
de si ce problème était donné dans un
jeu télévisé ou dans une expérience de
psychologie comme monsieur fille et moi
en avons parlé dans un vieil épisode
axiaux si jamais il y avait le par de
gaulle enveloppe qui est fait en
pratique je devais choisir si je change
ou pas payer tout le contexte qui est
qui est pertinent la prise de décision
notamment qui est-ce qui organise ça
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils organisent quel
est son budget c'est sûr tu dis bah
c'est un labo de recherche en psycho et
de fête fut riche et comme ça c'est du
mal a grossi à 50 d'ici à 50 dollars une
enveloppe je l'apprends oblige
ça m'étonnerait qu'ils ramènent les plus
brefs franchement c'est pour ça que cinq
raisonner un baiser en disant tu as des
attentes par rapport au contenu des
enveloppes
après t'imagines que les meilleurs
gagnent un jeu entre l'ex présentateur
et celui qui passe de son fumeux pour
mettre des contenus un peu crédible je
vois qu'on dira qu'il serait un peu un
centre de ça je pense vraiment je pense
que c'est un truc comme 4 et 8 ce serait
un bon choix mais je sais pas si je
devrais dire parce que peut-être qu'un
jour il ya un labo de psychologie qui va
faire l'expérience mais uniquement si
c'est un labo de psychologie qui
organise expérience partir de
peut-être 6 056 euros je garde en bloc
je pense c'est un bon choix je prends
soin qui mettrait beaucoup plus
effectives les épices par rapport aux
faits car j'avais su pas super bien
financée et puis bon et s'ils veulent
avoir des résultats crédibles ou neuf
ans après c'est ça à plein plein de gens
ont quand même je suis pas au moins je
sais pas au moins vingt quotidiens
catalans ont pâli cohorte intéressante
or plusieurs idéalement sur les faire
passer à plusieurs centaines de bon t'as
du mal à croire qu'ils mettraient
beaucoup d'argent peut-être que états
unis il votre est un peu plus aux états
unis à partir de reprendre ce à partir
de 2 euros je prends ouais c'est vrai
que ça le truc ce qu'en fait tu as envie
le problème est intéressant si tu prends
une façon très abstraite aime ça c'est
là qu'il est beau qu'il est
mathématiquement voilà que le problème
se pose vraiment façon paradoxale mais
en fait il peut pas se poser de cette
façon là et donc aux problèmes des deux
enveloppes
il n'y aura pas une réponse unique à
fournir indépendante de tout contexte la
réponse va être subjective mais la
subjectivité du problème ne le rend pas
moins intéressant pour autant en
pratique en particulier pour un bail
vient il va falloir exploiter le
contexte pour déterminer un préjugé sur
les contenus des deux ans globe est la
bonne décision va ensuite dépendre de ce
préjugé est donc en particulier fait
être sujets au contexte
ok supposant que l'on a ce préjugé
moment où on découvre que l' enveloppe
qu'on a choisi contient 2 euros il
s'agit alors d'appliquer la formule de
belize pour déterminer le contenu
probable de l'autre enveloppe où se
rencontrent en particulier que deux
sortes de contenus initiaux seulement
reste plausible à savoir 1,2 et 2,4 pour
effectuer le calcul de la formule de
bise ou disons plus simplement pour
déterminer la position du curseur de
tueries entre ces deux théories
il faut alors déterminer lesquelles de
ces montants étaient les plus probables
a priori imaginons en particulier que je
vous pose ce problème comme j'ai posé ya
quelques temps à eureka et à flournoy
est-ce que vous pensez que j'ai plus
probablement choisi un deux ou de quatre
imaginons que vous pensez que j'ai plus
probablement choisi de 4 pour déterminer
comment à donner mon enveloppe contient
2 euro doit mettre à jour vos crédence
il vous faut maintenant déterminer si
cette donnée est plus probable avec un
deux ou avec 2,4 et bien si vous avez
choisi au hasard l'une des deux
enveloppes
sachant que les enveloppes contenaient
un euro et 2 euros
la probabilité que vous tiriez 2 euros
d'autres enveloppes est égale à une
chance sur deux et il en est d'ailleurs
de même si les enveloppes contenaient
initialement 2 et 4 euros
du coup la donne et mon enveloppe
contient 2 euros est aussi surprenante
dans le cas 1 2 que dans le cas de
quatre et ça ça veut dire qu'il ne faut
pas bouger le curseur de turing en fait
dans le problème des deux enveloppes
entre les théories 1,2 et 2,4
le postérieur est égal ou préjugé plutôt
préjugés relatifs entre ces deux
théories et donc si vous pensiez plutôt
2/4 que 1 2 il vous faut conclure que a
posteriori aussi de 4 est aussi
légèrement plus probable que 1,2 et
c'est avec cette probabilité a
posteriori qu'il vous faut alors faire
le calcul d'espérance et dans ce cas
précis vous verrez que votre espérance
de gain sera supérieur on change on
enveloppe mais bien sûr dans d'autres
contextes vos préjugés pourrait être
différent ce qui peut vous conduire à
des calculs contrat factuel bahizire
différents et donc à des conclusions
différentes
et oui comme vous
des deux enfants la solution bayésienne
au paradoxe des deux enveloppes est
encore une fois une réponse du genre ça
dépend du contexte et au local en accès
achetés avec c'est compliqué et
notamment pour les matheux parmi vous
qui ont l'habitude des problèmes dont
les solutions sont indépendantes de tout
contexte ça peut paraître très frustrant
mais que voulez vous les vrais problèmes
ce qui s'oppose vraiment en pratique ce
sont des points compliqués qui dépendent
malheureusement souvent du contexte
néanmoins j'aimerais insister sur le
fait que la subjectivité du problème le
fait qu'ils soient sujets aux données
auxquelles on a accès ceci n'implique
pas que la conclusion est arbitraire pas
du tout et ça ça correspond au fait plus
générale que les préjugés qu'on a au
moment où nous présente le problème ou
au moment où nous demande de changer ou
non dans glock
ces données ne sont pas n'importe quoi
elles viennent notamment de la montagne
de données qu'on a collecté durant toute
notre vie comme le disait le bas est
bien convaincu
dennis lynch est le postérieur
d'aujourd'hui est le préjugé de demain
autrement dit pour monbahusiens le
préjugé devrait résulter de longs
calculs bayésiens nécessairement
approximatif en pratique qui s'appuient
eux mêmes sur l'immensité des données
précédemment collectés dans notre vie en
pratique le préjugé
c'est avant tout un postérieur très
difficile à calculer
c'est pour cela que en pratique prendre
le temps de calculer les préjugés
adéquat c'est souvent une énorme partie
du travail à faire pour devenir de bons
bayésiens pragmatique et justement dans
le cas des deux enveloppes me semble que
retient en particulier et fribourg nord
avait un calcul particulièrement
intéressant à effectuer est j'ai pas
envie de les embrasser
mais ils les ont pas fait ses calculs
oui parce que les choix des contenus des
enveloppes un deux ou de quatre
c'est moi qui les ai choisis et la
manière dont j'ai les ai choisis n'a
rien d'arbitraire
avant tout je voulais que le problème
soit intéressant quel que soit le
montant que la personne tient or si
j'avais choisi 1 et 2 alors avec une
probabilité 1/2 la personne que j'aurais
fait jouer pourrait tirer un euro et là
la question que la personne se serait
posé ce sera entre les cas 1 2 et 50
centimes 1 euro et la personne se serait
alors peut-être dit il est peu probable
que j'ai choisi une somme non entière si
leur procès qu en pratique j'ai choisi
2,4 et pas 1 2 et bien ce raisonnement
que j'ai fait pour choisir les contenus
des deux enveloppes probablement un bout
j'ai aurait pu deviner